Singapore generated around 16.3 billion
pounds of solid waste in 2022
is dumped here
Singapore's only landfill
and a portion of semi-cal landfill is
already 90 full base of estimate the
island will be completely fueled by
2035. Singapore smaller than the size of
New York City is also one of the most
dense countries in the world so it's
tackling its trash by turning all of
this
into this in order to prolong the life
of the landfill I mean where can we form
another language
the current key to Singapore's trash
problem is incineration
while 55 of all waste is recycled
according to the Nea 42 goes to the
waste to energy plants where it's burned
leaving only Ash and three percent of
solid waste to go to the landfill for
just one incineration site trucks
collect around 6 million pounds of
Municipal solid wasted day
after weighing it gets dropped off here
okay this is our reception hall we have
1 to 15 numbers yet according to
Singapore's National environment agency
42 percent of trash collected in 2021
went to waste energy plants like this
one
there are four active waste to energy
plants in Singapore what can be
processed at the facility moves onto the
waste bunker at the crane control room
operators lift massive amounts of the
mixed waste and feed it into these
incinerators which reach temperatures of
about 1800 degrees Fahrenheit
all of the heat from the waste
incineration creates steam in the
boilers which is then converted into
electricity through these steam turbine
generators
this can generate an export about 120
megawatts per hour which can meet the
demand of about 240 000 households the
to us one less than any plant is one of
the highest electricity generation
facility the resulting flue gas is
passed through a catalytic fabric filter
to remove particles
according to the EPA these incinerators
tend to generate slightly more
greenhouse gas emissions than natural
gas for the amount of electricity
produced but less than Kohler oil then
the cleaned gas goes through the ID plan
I will stacked height is 120 meter with
online analyzer it is continuously
monitored we maintained the emission
limit another other byproduct of the
process Ash
lots of it
according to the Nea the amount of ash
left is roughly 10 percent of the
original volume of the waste after scrap
metal is removed the remainder is
transported to the next point of the
process
loaded at 12 's Main transfer station
all the way here takes about four hours
semicau is located five miles south from
Singapore our Hibachi is a huge watch is
a more than 85 meter longs it has a
cargo of about 3 500 meters which is
equivalent to one and a half swing pool
size in one day about four million
pounds of Ash and non-incenerable waste
is transferred here loaded into dump
trucks and brought to these cells for
final disposal this is considered phase
two of the landfill which is still a
lagoon but phase one this is the phase
one of the landfill cell about 90
percent of this land fuel cell has
already completed refueled as you can
see here mostly contains the
incineration bottom mesh and also the
non-insirable ways that we receive from
the mainland Singapore to ensure the
landfill does not contaminate the
surrounding environment there are
several measures in place over time the
land filling and rains will increase the
water level inside the phase two so if
the water level increases we need to
pump down the water out to the Sea
before the waters are pumped out to the
Sea they have been treated by the
wastewater treatment plant semicau's
perimeter bond is
from getting into the
teeth
is a coffee powder when you have a
filter with a coffee powder you put the
water over it and over time this water
will start leaked out is it coffee
powder you have here is actually the
insulation water mesh and the water is
what you call a liquid
semicau landfills phase one was
commissioned in 1999. it's phase two
area commissioned in 2015 is currently
about 10 percent filled in the 60s
before they built racial energy plants
the waste actually go to lonohar loose
and then they dump this they go there
they just throw it there and it's buried
So currently we don't have such things
because all domestic waste goes to our
local waste energy plant which we have
visited so what they receive
from become always reduced to Ash they
almost come here incinerations plants
have become more popular in Europe and
Asia especially in areas with limited
space but these plants actually
decreased a number in the United States
from 103 in 1999 to just over 70 in
2020. critics are still concerned about
pollutants and the incineration process
without proper equipment and note that
it's only a short-term solution
with the landfill projected to be
completely filled by 2035. Singapore has
only delayed the trash crisis
the country is looking for ways to
recycle incinerated bottom Ash into
other materials reducing the amount
brought to semicau we're looking in
local universities look at it's a
possibility to recycle this ash into new
materials we say for roads work the
government also hopes to increase
recycling rates to 70 by 2030 which
requires consumer education currently
about 40 percent of items placed in
recycling bins cannot actually be
recycled due to contamination as part of
this Focus we actually plans to work
together in an area such as the three
hours which is to reduce reuse as well
as recycle
foreign